this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
please watch the entire video before
giving an anticoagulant shot
this video will teach you how to give
yourself a shot of anticoagulant
medicine also called a blood thinner
blood thinners help prevent clots from
forming inside your blood vessels
before you begin you will need
alcohol wipes
your pre-filled syringe of anticoagulant
medicine and a sharps box
the main parts of the syringe are
the barrel containing the medicine
the plunger
the needle cap and the needle
select your injection site at least two
inches to the right or left of your
belly button or on either of your thighs
a caregiver may also use these
instructions to give you a shot on
either side of your back upper arms or
upper buttocks
use a different injection site each day
to avoid swelling or bruising
[Music]
and take your shot at the same time each
day
be sure to
follow your doctor's instructions
do not skip any doses
do not inject more medicine than
prescribed
[Music]
step one before you begin wash your
hands with soap and water and then dry
them
step 2 clean the skin over the injection
site by rubbing with an alcohol wipe in
a circular motion
step three to open your syringe peel the
foil cover off the back
do not push the syringe through the foil
cover because it could damage the
syringe
step four hold the syringe sideways by
the barrel then pull the needle cap
straight off without bending the needle
there will be an air bubble in the
medicine do not press the plunger to
squirt the air bubble out of the barrel
step 5 with your free hand pinch and
hold an inch of skin at the injection
site
insert the needle at a 90 degree angle
through your skin and into the fatty
tissue beneath it
step six
slowly press the plunger to deliver all
of the medicine including the air bubble
step seven pull the needle straight out
of your skin
step eight press down firmly on the
plunger to activate the safety guard
which covers the needle
step 9 throw away the used syringe in
your sharps box
call your doctor if you notice increased
bleeding
or bruising rash numbness or tingling
especially in your legs